enfin ça préoccupe de trains sur la
ligne paris limoges toulouse
cette ligne sera la première en france à
être équipés de ce type de matériel
en 2002 alors avant de discuter avec
jean claude allanic qui est à côté nous
nous allons découvrir ce train
pendulaire
on commençait à se demander si ce
n'était pas un train fantôme
le premier train pendulaire français est
enfin sur les rails ou presque ce sera
pour 2002 entre paris limoges et
toulouse il permet en fait de circuler
plus vite dans les tracés dans lequel il
y à des courbes et donc à la fois de
gagner du temps et du et du confort ce
dans un train normal qui prend un virage
à trop grande vitesse la force
centrifuge s'exerce aussi bien sur les
liquides que sur les passagers pas très
agréable avec la technologie pendulaire
chaque voiture s'incline à tour de rôle
pour contrebalancer cette poussée
centrifuge un balancement obtenue grâce
un système de vérins installé au niveau
des bogies le système est déclenchée
automatiquement à l'entrée dans une
courbe sans que les passagers s'en rende
compte du besoin de ralentir ce qui
permettra de gagner 25 minutes entre
paris et toulouse avec des pointes à 220
km à l'heure le train pendulaire ira
plus vite qu'un train classique et ce ne
sera quand même pas le tgv en tgv en
gros on multiplie la vitesse par deux on
passe de 160 à 300 km heure en
pendulaires on va gagner en temps de
parcours simplement 5 à 10%
donc les rapports coûts avantages sont
différents
moins rapide et plus économique que le
tgv le train pendulaire devrait dans
l'avenir intéressés sur tous les réseaux
régionaux
un projet de ter pendulaires existe déjà
il permettrait de relier clermont
ferrand 1 lyon